ce qui a changé en vous qu'est ce qui a
changé
moi je pense que j'ai c'est surtout la
prise de recul c'est à dire que j'estime
que plus comment gérer la situation ne
me mettait vraiment en colère
j'avoue parce que jouer cela injuste de
ce que je ne puisse pas voir ma fille
régulièrement puisque je donne j'avais
demandé de manière amiable
la mère de mon enfant que je puisse voir
ma fille au moins tous les quinze jours
le week-end au début ça ça ça
fonctionnait et puis subitement l a
décidé d'arrêter parce que ça
ce que l'association a raconté justement
cet échange avec les perles c'est de
prendre du recul et de l'encouragement
justement à faire les démarches
nécessaires la justice pour me voir
retrouver justement maj les doigts
légitime en tant que père je vois mes
filles tous les samedis en journée
jusqu'à ce que trois ans après s'arrête
[Musique]
week-end sur deux et la moitié des
vacances vous avez encore besoin de
l'association malgré tout oui
l'association oui heureusement
l'association au quotidien en échange il
ya des papas qui racontent leur vécu et
aussi on se remonte le moral qu'on a des
coups de blues qu'on a besoin
d'information des ans et qui a des papas
qui sont passés par là où qui passent
par là aussi encore donc on s'entraide
et vous personnellement alors moi
j'apporte mon vécu à travers les
différents pour les iphone procédure que
j'ai fait et aussi
les échanges avec la meilleure quand ça
se passe pas bien quand je dois pas
aller à la crèche à la pédiatre aussi on
a remarqué que l'on connaît pas bien nos
droits donc en fait on a remarqué en
fait on a les mêmes droits que les
mamans et beaucoup de papas délaisse un
peu ce droit sans le savoir